[Music]
what is [__] posting on R Duke am I
going to get pissed at this am I the
[__] for quitting my job for a much
better offer I just got the job offer of
my dreams $7 million base salary
Millions more in bonus if I perform well
and I get to move to a lovely and I get
to move to a lovely sunny State sounds
hor
the only problem is I signed a contract
with my previous company that's supposed
to extend to
2029 I felt so unsupported at my company
they didn't care about my work at all
they bought thousands of shirts with my
department logo on it shot off fireworks
every time we had a successful project
and paid our clients hundreds of dollars
to attend our shitty Department events
but that doesn't even count that's so
[__] lame compared to other companies
where the CEO personally offers people
in my position a daily 30 minute deep
throat session okay there go why would
you post this on our Duke what is Duke
funny the the college yeah what do you
mean what like what's the vibe there I
don't know just like a normal College
Normal College I don't know what normal
college
is I mean I guess I would say it's
probably a little bit like there's
definitely like Rich Southern Vibes
there for sure all right yeah you have
the [__] you have the notra there
looks like
yeah do you have a hunchback in that
Tower you have to go to school ding
ding no but one of like the there was
like these unspoken graduation
requirements and one of them was you had
to climb on top of that
Dome never did
that so also you should you had to [__]
in the gardens that was another one
didn't do
that I was a virgin [__] people would
like black out and then be like we got
to do we got to climb the top of Baldwin
or whatever and they would go and
fall and [__] die yeah can you
believe that [__] yeah yeah my college
felt like a corporate
campus see I mean you've been to se Sun
the library which feels old everything
else feels like like a dentist office or
it like felt pretty
Cy to me okay that's good to know yeah
like you guys had a
pool that was sick I always thought like
an outdoor [__] just chill pool
wasn't it like off the main
little yeah that thing I never went
there did you have old people in your
classes was it all
young um like is Duke like that can you
can you be 35 and go I want to apply
Duke also was like a big grad school so
there was like older people walking
around like in med school or yeah
they're around bus school they're not in
like uh yeah the bachelor programs that
was all seon was funny they take anyone
really I had a communications class
there's a woman in there probably no
younger than
78 that's kind of sick it is but she
didn't understand any
modern technology so they'd have to like
pause the lecture and explain cell
phones to
[Laughter]
her she like so when people are
online and it started out cute yeah and
then it turned into that
my friend's in a music class right now
like a music school yeah he's going
through this like months long music
program okay just seems like fun to go
back to school for a little bit like
he's on like a [__] daily thing he's
got like homework he's got like projects
that he's working on whenever I hit him
up he's like sorry man I was in like
sessions all day like with my class and
you're like what are you learning in
there yeah yeah I I mean the closest
thing I did to that as an adult was
acting class but like the one I was in
Leslie con part of it is that you meet
up after so it's like a it's like once a
week I think and it was like so they
really want you to [__] yeah I think
it's like setup designed for people in
LA to like just it's just
Tinder but
um so like I think once a week it was
like Tuesday nights it was like for five
hours or something insane and you like
would read text and then you'd go up in
front of the class and like act out a
scene and do all the [__] but then you
get your assignment and you get your
group and you got to meet up every
single day that's what she says every
single day during the week at someone's
[__] apartment and run the scenes
together all I've ever heard about
acting classes is they're massively
horny I believe that I could definitely
see that being the case for I have
friends that take acting classes and
they go dude it's like annoying yeah
like annoying how much how much [__]
I'm getting no like how nothing can
happen in that class without someone
making it about I want to [__] that
person yeah and it's
just he says then it's weird because you
he wants to be an actor so when he's
getting feedback from some people cut
out the horny [__] yeah yeah well that's
what that's kind of what he was saying
is that when he's trying to get feedback
about things it just feels off because
the person's you're killing it yeah yeah
yeah it's just like he's not getting you
know he doesn't know how good he's doing
because he's getting head the whole
time it's hard to tell how good he's
doing the scene not again when he's
looking at her back
[__] I really wanted to do the scene
today but
fine yeah I've heard acting classes are
just horny as hell yep so yeah it's art
it's just an extension of art school
it's for people who Miss art school yeah
but it's also like I feel like actors
normal like I don't know there's a lot
of also like Attractive people that yeah
want to act because they're like oh I
have this going for me I might as well
try and do this definitely so it's just
young attractive horny people that need
to meet people in LA and are like oh I
want to be productive at the same time
it's always really funny when an
attractive actor goes you know I think
I'm going to try standup yeah they go to
open mic and a [__] hateful
spiteful dudes with Asbergers in there
like get this [__] out the stage
and they're up there and they're like so
I was getting [__] last
[Laughter]
night you like you you're right you guys
can late right the whole room just
nope so I was getting head last night
again like I get sucked off too much you
ever get like sucked off too
[Laughter]
much you know you know fellas there is
getting sucked off too much yeah I know
you're all dreaming about it in here let
me explain
yeah I've had a couple people hit me up
from that acting class on DMS been like
hey man you're killing it can I blow you
no just be like check in like yo man how
you doing yeah like you know whatever
and then I'll go to their profile and
they have like 3 million followers I'm
like oh [__] you blew up you [__]
made it holy [__] they'll be like you
still acting I'm like yeah man I'm you
know still going out for some
stuff I'm still waiting for that right
for the right one I'm around yeah yeah
I'm in the city man I'm in the town
that's a vague ass answer yeah I need I
need anyone who's in the acting class
right now to comment the horniest story
they
got I would also love to know that yeah
that that to me like Barry the show
that's what was so funny to me about his
like um like girlfriend's character she
just I feel like she nailed that like
I'm the special snowflake here so well
just you know without saying it
obviously her lines were delivering it I
definitely watched that but I forget
are you not caught up no oh you gotta
binge this watch the first season like
half of it and
then I think I just stopped Sarah
Goldberg man killed that role yeah I'm
trying to think I know there was some
funny stories from acting class one of
the ones that I'm that like comes to
mind is this [__] Australian guy got
way too into this scene where he got
angry he started throwing [__] across
the stage hey and all of us were
like chill [__] was breaking we were
like yo like crying and
and I remember the teacher being like
that was really good cuz we were all
like holy [__] you know he just and I
remember think I got to Lost like that
yeah man you know so did he just come
right out of it yeah yeah like cut he's
like okay great it's like holy [__] that
is frightening me yeah dude you [__]
You Got What It Takes man I don't got
that I don't have that
sorry